one two three go
hi welcome to a new episode of project
camp
in this video you will see us harvesting
some potatoes with our very direct
neighbors
because this is our land and this is
antonius and fernandez land they asked
us for some help
afterwards we will also harvest our
veggie box and we will explain you a bit
more why we do that
and
this year we have been visited by a lot
of wild animals
and at the end you will see a very very
very cute visit we had from some friends
i hope you enjoy it
[Music]
so what is the plan for now guys
we are going to harvest some potatoes to
help out fernando and antonio our
closest neighbors
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey boy
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so harvesting potatoes on fernanda in
antonio's field goes like this
you choose either to dig or to pick
if you choose to dig you take the hole
hit the soil exactly at the edge of the
water ditch make it loose and search for
the little tasty gems
then
you throw them behind you and repeat
you need to dig hard enough to go deep
but at the same time gentle and precise
otherwise you will damage or cut the
potatoes in half
which will be then followed by a more or
less happy antonio fernanda who then
gives you a private lesson on how to
work properly
if you choose to pick it's easier
just throw the fresh harvested potatoes
in the bucket and the damaged and two
small ones in another
nevertheless you're gonna be exhausted
anyway since it's a huge field it's
super hot and the potatoes don't come
out of the soil by themselves
[Music]
[Music]
very good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
holy
next step is simple
hop on antonio's tractor and take a ride
to the tiny house where they store the
potatoes
don't forget to enjoy the lovely
portuguese countryside the ride is short
but be careful to not fall off the
tractor
since the road is quite bumpy and you
are sitting on the side of a giant
shovel
then hop off
empty the buckets and start again from
the beginning
[Music]
yes
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
if you made it to this point
congratulations you have passed the
neighborly potato test
you can see yourself now as a true
portuguese neighbor
and you will be rewarded soon with a
typical portuguese busher
a delicious snack
which is in our case
crispy sardines local cheese
bread
fried and sweet flower boards
and three bottles of tasty homemade wine
okay
this is gonna go in this one
is asking if you're making a video
[Laughter]
so today we are here at nunu and sara's
place
they are friends and they are also
farmers and they are usually the ones
that
bring a veggie box to us and we showed a
video last season you might remember
them
today it's different today we come here
to their place to harvest our box and
this is why we want to explain you
slightly why we are doing this
so sari nunu are part of a network of
farmers which is called csi that stands
for community supported agriculture
and that stands for like also creating a
link between farmers and consumers that
it's like a shared responsibility
between risks and rewards because being
a small farmer it involves a lot of
risks
in the sense of like they are dependent
on a lot of variables that are beyond
their hands as weather as
water supply as actually health and
strength in their body and this is
actually the case why we are here
because nunu got sick and it means that
sarah is not able to
take care of the garden and harvest and
make the box and distribute it all by
herself so we as consumers come here and
harvest the box ourselves
oh i've tried to seed some carrots on
the side of the tomatoes but it didn't
go so well
yes come on through
um
come coming down here
so here we have a new new variety that
they've tried yellow corsets
and they're like proper radio activity
[Music]
twist it or use a knife
yeah courgettes are surprisingly spiky
yeah
[Music]
you'll have to take a yellow one back as
well
these are really nice
[Music]
[Music]
i harvested
this line
okay what's gonna happen now
so now part of the mission is to harvest
some of the delicious super big
strawberries look at this guy over here
that's really perfect
[Music]
oh well but i wanted
[Music]
so maybe it would be easy for you guys
to understand what actually csa means if
sarah just answers a few questions
and
maybe you could say why did you choose
to become part of csa
so yeah community supported agriculture
is interesting
for both i think the us and
the clients from our point of view it
from and from
any farmer who's doing csa it's
interesting because you have a certain
security you know it's a subscription
base so you it's easier to plan
um your farm uh you have that sort of
base income that you can sort of rely on
and
at least
near to long term
um
it also means that with the box
kind of
products we can diversify in our farm
which is not only good for the
environment but it also means that it
makes us more resilient to things like
crop failures or
strange weather which is happening more
and more you know one
product might suffer but then we'll
still have
other stuff that we can put in the boxes
um
and i think then for
the communities of the people who buy
the boxes it's interesting because well
it's closer so your food arrives to you
a lot fresher
um
and
actually the quality of the food is
often better not just because of the
farming techniques but
nowadays um
products can be harvested before they're
ready so that they travel better
and that
sort of
has a negative effect on the nutrients
and the vitamins that you find in your
food so hopefully it's healthier for you
too
um and it reduces uh food mass
um
[Music]
answer the question you answered like
the three questions i had okay perfect
have we done that why is it beneficial
for you you had it prepared
but maybe one more question is like
would be
are there any downsides of being part in
this
csa
downside here like
sometimes it can be a little bit
challenging to get the
planning right so quantities
um
you know you've got to have
enough diversity for a box but also
enough quantity
to
make sense so but that with time is
getting better i found that a lot more
difficult in my first year than i do
um this year so yeah
practice makes perfect
who said thank you that's it for the
interview and i think we can continue
with the harvest
but then i don't know what happened
but then i ate this cabbage
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yesterday we harvest really beautiful
veggies for incredible diverse baskets
which i want to show you now
there are a few things missing like the
strawberries they were too delicious to
wait for today
but i just want you to see this richness
in colors in
nutrients and in flavors
we got
potatoes we got fresh garlic we got a
lot of aromatics
edible flowers
cabbage
kohlhabi
zucchini in
different colors
and yeah basil yeah summer is coming and
with summer a lot of diversity is coming
and within the scheme of csa as we
explained a little bit
when something is missing they replace
with something else so in the case
yesterday we didn't get
letters
so we got extra beans which sounds like
a very cool deal
we get this box
once a week which is a big luxury for us
and
yeah this is it for now i just take the
box back so that abby can do her magic
they fell into the water
really yeah
because they followed otis
baby
[Music]
last week we got visited by some new
cute neighbors
it seems they live close by in the
mountains
because they just followed otis and
debbie where they worked on the yoga
deck
the mom and dad were also there but they
got scared by otis and run away for some
reason the puppies didn't
we played a bit with them and then
brought them back to the mountains where
the parents were able to find them
it worked fine with the two of them we
also saw them with the mother but the
little fellow with the white boss came
back to us a few times
we called him first brutus then johnny
then flingflong
he seems really to like us
but yeah we still tried to bring him
back to his mother
so we said goodbye to him
let's see if it was for the last time
that's it for this video i hope you guys
enjoyed this episode and if you like
what we do in project camp you can also
support us on patreon and you will
actually see our videos one week ahead
and you can also vote for our thumbnail
next week we will do a review on our
electric chainsaw
and for today we have so many potatoes
and i need to cut some
[Music]
[Music]
you